la mesoescala.
Y las técnicas sustractivas de la industria del silicón
no pueden hacer esto bien.
No pueden grabar obleas así de bien.
Pero este proceso es tan suave,
que podemos sacar estos objetos del fondo usando la fabricación aditiva
y hacer cosas sorprendentes en cuestión de segundos,
abriendo camino a nuevas tecnologías de sensores,
nuevas técnicas para la administración de drogas,
nuevas aplicaciones de laboratorio-en-un-chip,
cosas realmente revolucionarias.
La posibilidad de hacer una parte con propiedades de acabado final
en tiempo real,
realmente facilita la fabricación en 3D,
y para nosotros esto es muy excitante porque significa tener posesión
de la intersección entre hardware, software y ciencia molecular,
y no puedo esperar a ver lo que diseñadores e ingenieros
alrededor del mundo van a poder hacer con esta grandiosa herramienta.
Gracias por escuchar.
(Aplausos)